now we did at one o'clock did get a
report of a wind gust near 40 to 50
miles per hour in green valley
specifically at mcdonald ranch and
that's where we sent victoria saha right
now live in location there uh reports of
a downed tree victoria
yeah ted we were lucky enough this
homeowner let us come to her backyard
just check out the damage here look at
the roots out and the sprinkler system
also taken out i'm going to have my
photog show you a little bit about this
tree is humongous it's taking up a lot
of the side of her house i did get to
chat with the homeowner she said around
one o'clock it just went dark it was
loud lightning thunder whatever you
could name it she said it was so loud
she didn't even hear this tree fall
until after everything was over she
peeked out of her kitchen window and saw
the damage and of course she was shocked
and sent us these pictures she says that
she is waiting for her landscape
guy to come out here check the damage
and hopefully remove the tree soon
reporting live victoria saha live local
now thank you so much